this is a video I'm making for Avante
the young man who was working two jobs
with a 1-year-old who's struggling and
said he was sick and tired of being poor
and didn't know how to get out I didn't
have time to answer you when I was
walking but I wanted to take this minute
to give you a longer answer I'll read
you the tweet and maybe we'll put it up
on the screen to ivante the young man
who stopped me at the grocery store
working two jobs with one-year-old who
asked advice on how to get ahead I gave
you a short answer because I was in a
rush and it ate at me so if you follow
me here maybe you'll read this what
you're going through is tough being so
young and already having to support a
child is not easy but you have the
opportunity to become an amazing
inspiration in a way I never could your
success story will become your sermon
that being said on to the advice you're
going to need to assume that luck isn't
real or that it applies to everyone else
but you because the only way you're
going to get out of your surroundings is
by having something of value that other
people want and right now the only thing
you have is your time with low skills to
trade which is a hard game to play you
have to trade a lot of it only to get a
little so your main objective is to have
the time to learn a skill while
providing for your family that means in
the short term your family may have to
suffer scratch that your family will
suffer but better now when they're to
young to remember than when they're too
old to forget again not forever but for
now so these are the things you're going
to have to do and this isn't dabble
stuff this is wake the [__] up because
if you don't you're going to Blink and
be 30 and in the same spot but worse
number one cut all costs and I mean all
costs you don't eat out anymore for
anything and if you're hungry you deal
with it if it's not from a discount
grocery store you don't buy it clothing
ha what you've got is everything you
need for the next 2 years period no
exceptions reuse trade or go to Goodwill
you go to work you go home and home is
ideally with your family and when I say
family your folks and if you don't have
folks who have got who' got room or a
couch or a basement that you can stay at
the worst case is with another family
also trying to make it and save so it's
six of you eight of you 10 of you in one
spot all splitting it all of you
contributing and it's going to be as
cheap as you possibly can number two
increase your income you're working two
jobs your free time want you to spend
applying to other jobs closer to what
you want to do he said he didn't like
either of the things that he was doing
at that time so any at home phone sales
job has starter roles that require zero
experience to pay 40,000 a year or more
do that and work your other job in
between if you can't drive Uber if you
don't have a car save up until you do
number three the easiest thing to sell
is someone else's stuff so start there
then learn how to buy stuff for cheap
and then flip it the bigger the thing
the more you make you go from flipping
cards to Furniture to home and the limit
never really stops from there on Final
note I could hear the stress in your
voice when you were talking to me about
your situation it sounded like you
didn't know what to do sadness comes
from a lack of options it's a feeling of
hopelessness but whenever you feel that
I want you to think this is ignorance
not sadness it means I don't know enough
and that I can control you asked me to
come work for free but I have no need
for low skilled labor but I do have a
need for high-skilled beasts it's why I
make the books and the courses and the
content everywhere for free so use those
then get yourself a highp paying job and
every day apply for higher paying ones I
recommend sales to start then once you
get in there for the love of God work
until your fingers bleed because you
have no other option you have no luck
nothing is going to work out for you
you're not going to catch a break you're
going to have to make it happen you're
going to have to force it you've got to
become undeniable and the best news is
is that you can do that in less than a
year so that's my advice number one cut
all your costs everything number two
work more to make more and apply to
better jobs and then learn to sell three
start selling more expensive stuff and
then eventually Stell your own the game
is Just trading up over and over and
over again you're just a few trades away
from a very different financial
situation so Avante I wanted to add on
top of that you're in a tough spot and I
think some of the words I probably just
said to you might hopefully hit home
some where but one of the harp things
that you got going on right now is like
when I saw you you were wearing
relatively nice clothes and I wasn't
going to like bash you on it when I saw
you but I want to take the opportunity
to say like you know better you know
what I mean like you know that like if
you're struggling with money that that's
the last thing that you should spend
money on right and um I think one of the
difficulties especially when you're
younger is you've got your friends you
got your family and especially if
they're all poor then they have terrible
views around money they might not
approve of all the stuff you're learning
on the internet and trying to try these
new things out and the real real is like
you're going to fail a lot and they're
going to see say see Told You So and the
tough part is is they're going to be
right most of the time except it's one
of those things where it's 99% right but
100% wrong is that anybody who bets
against you for this thing being the
thing is usually going to be right it's
just like a parent who says you're going
to break up with this person you're
going to break up with this person
you're going to break up with this
person but they're right with every
single person you ever date except for
the person you marry and then they're
100% wrong and if you have the
perspective of listening to that it can
be incredibly disheartening and so
number one is I want you to go on a on a
different information diet so you need
to be able to ignore all the stuff that
they're giving you because like the best
way to stay poor is to listen to poor
people about how to get rich you're
already taking great steps by like
watching content doing this stuff just
keep doing more of that and I'm sure
your girl who you know you have your
baby with that's your world like anybody
who does who's not trying to build a
vonte 2.0 with you doesn't deserve your
time because like right now you have a
wallet of money and you got a wallet of
minutes and like every single person
you're choosing to pay minutes to or pay
dollars to has to earn their keep and
earning their keep in this season of
your life is them helping you get to
where you want to go now I don't know
what you're making in your job I'm just
going to assume the extreme scenario of
you're making a minimum wage at both
jobs and you're working 80 hours doing
that I get it and I respect the hustle
which is why I'm making this video you
need to get more for your time and right
now the extra time on top of that 80 is
you sleeping and probably spending time
with your kid and what I'm going to say
people in your surroundings will say
like that guy's extreme or that guy he's
he's not balanced and the answer is yes
I am extreme and I am unbalanced for the
season that you're in I think you should
be too because the thing is just like if
you don't take action on this 5 years is
going to go by and nothing's going to
change cuz you're not going to get a
head like you need to get your head
firmly above water cuz you probably
barely feel like you can keep your head
above surface right that's where all
that stress is coming from and you don't
know what to do so to get the water
lower you've got to lower your time
budget and your money budget and I want
to go really extreme with you and I'm
not telling you to do anything I didn't
do all right I owned my car in cash
which I think was A5 or $6,000 car and I
slept in a room with another dude in a
house that had six other people in it
and we all split it so I wasn't in a
terrible neighborhood I just paid $400 a
month in a nice neighborhood cuz I
didn't have my own place and so I had to
split my kitchen and I had to deal with
the fact that three of them had dogs and
were [__] and piss everywhere all the
time it sucked but you know it would
have sucked more not being able to have
the money to buy the courses and the
seminars and the workshops that I was
able to attend with the extra that I
saved so I could learn my next skills
and so right now food and shelter is the
only thing you spend money on and you're
going to drop everything else and you're
going to drop those expenses to the
greatest degree possible and either your
girl is working if she's working then
you can have child care if she's not
working to take care of the kid then you
need to say listen sweetie like I got to
do this for us right now and so like
you're putting your sacrifice in which
is your sacrificing your career so we
can you can be with the kid I need to
sacrifice the kid right now so I can
have the career so that together as a
family we're balanced rather than the
individual so there's two levels of
balance I want you to think about one is
the macro which is like you can be
balanced over your lifespan when you're
retired you'll have more time you can go
to Europe you can do whatever the other
stuff is right and also you can be
balanced in a family unit your wife
might spend more time with the kid than
she does on her career but you're going
to spend more time in your than you do
with the kid for now cut out the people
who are taking your time easy way to see
this is like if the people in your life
don't have bigger dreams for you than
you do ignore all of their advice let's
just ignore them entirely and I know
that that's simple to say and hard to do
but you're in a hard situation and I
think the question is whether you can be
harder than your circumstances right now
and you have to be to get out of this
luck has already dealt you a [__] hand
let's assume he's never going to give
you the right hand you're never going to
get lucky but you still need to win and
so now it's like how do I do that if you
have a car you can have more flexible
hours if you drive Uber that's something
that I recommend for a lot of people if
you don't have a car you need to save up
as fast as you can to get one buy one in
cash negotiate try and get yourself $5
to $10,000 car in cash you don't have
payments you just have the insurance
which because it's a cheap car will be
less the remainder of your time and you
got to tell your lady this is like I'm
going to be spending 4 hours a day every
day watching these videos and this isn't
me Doom scrolling on YouTube I need you
to pick one skill that you want to have
and only consume stuff about that this
is my one thing I'll let you buy it's a
timer you can buy for five bucks not
your phone when you set the timer and
you set it for those 4 hours a day and
every time you look away you stop the
timer you do four hours of real work of
studying the skill after you've done
enough of that work and you're like
what's enough 20 hours like you're like
oh I can do that soon yeah I know that's
why I'm telling you you can get out of
this fast you can switch those 4 hours
of you learning the basics of that skill
just spending the rest of your time
being the most amazing applicant to new
jobs that exist in the world I didn't
say go apply to jobs I said be the best
candidate that has ever applied and
you're like I don't have experience and
you can address that like what I don't
have an experience I will make up for an
hustle and you prove that by messaging
multiple people at every company with a
snippet personalized to each of them you
know what other people do like they take
a half step they copy and paste the same
thing to all four people and you know
what the four people do yeah yeah he
copy and pasted the same message to me
don't do that be personal look at the HR
recruiter look at the head of talent
look at director of whatever and message
each of them on LinkedIn if you don't
have a LinkedIn go get one it's free and
when you submit your resume put a
personalized cover letter on it after
reading from the website what that
business is about when you read the job
description good job description say
what they want the person to do and say
like I will be able to help do this
thing because of these things right and
especially a lower level role your
resume is not going to matter as much
don't let anybody around you say that or
fool you into that what will matter
especially for low level roles is hustle
so every employer wants to see is
somebody who's going to go out of their
way to go above and beyond and so you
demonstrate that you're going to go
above and beyond and guess what's going
to happen you're going to do this for
five different places you're going to
write a custom thing it's going to take
you 4 hours to do the research write the
custom thing message 20 people cuz it's
going to be four people at all five
places you know what's going to happen
nothing cuz you're not lucky so what are
you going to have to do got to be
undeniable do you think if you appli to
a thousand places like that over the
next 6 months you wouldn't get a job I
think you would you think if like after
you got off your shift you drove over
and you said hey I just want to let you
know not in a creepy way you say hey
just want let you know I apply to put my
resume I messaged a couple of you guys I
just want to let you know I'm really
excited about the opportunity don't want
to be overbearing but if you guys would
give me a shot I promise I'll will work
harder than any other candidate here and
I'd like to just show you that I'm
demonstrating that by these things so
you're like I have proof that I'm saying
I'm not just making I have proof that I
will work harder and you know what'll
happen one of them say I'll give you a
shot and then when they give you that
shot shove it in everyone's face how
hard you work not by what you say but by
what you do be silent and just kill look
at what the top guy does and do twice as
much as that guy does be Kobe for
whatever the job is if you don't know
the whole story about Kobe he did three
practices a day while everyone else did
one or two because he wanted to get
ahead and in the beginning he was worse
than them and then he got as good as
them and then he became better than them
and he kept doing three practices a day
until eventually no one could catch up
because if they were doing three
practice a day they would just keep up
with his rate of progress but he got
ahead and so the guy who's number one at
whatever that business is probably works
better than you and he works longer than
you and so you can't just match him to
get ahead cuz he'll always be ahead you
got to match his current effort and then
do your I'm going to get ahead of you
effort like when he clocks out is when
your work clocks in that's when Aon 2.0
clocks in and the thing is is like if
you can adopt this like if you can
really internalize this you're going to
crush you're going to win you can make
luck not a factor when I had Jacob my
19-year-old my son I'm kidding when I
was talking to him he I think he was 16
actually I was 15 or 16 when I started
talking about this imagine he has even
less reason to get a job than you all
right less experience I gave him three
words and he said he still remembers in
this day I said volume negates luck if
you need to put it put it on the back of
your phones as a reminder of yourself
because in the beginning the volume
you're going to do is the timer of you
watching the videos and taking the notes
and watching the videos taking learning
the lingo learning the language so that
when you get into an interview you know
what to say and then reps is going to be
watching mock interviews on YouTube
watching people who are hiring experts
talk about the best ways to present
watch some of Lela videos about how to
interview correctly you do that stuff
you'll put yourself ahead of other
people volume okay cool now you're like
okay but I'm not getting interviews
volume negates luck crank the timer
start doing the Reps one a day two a day
three a day four a day 5 a day six a day
10 a day every single day you're like
wait that's 40 messages that are
personalized and 10 cover letters yep
that'll probably take about 4 hours and
then what do you do tomorrow set the
timer you do it again next day set the
timer you do it again what do you do the
next day you set the timer you do it a
[__] again and you keep doing it and
on the ones that you really really like
you drive over there after you get off
your shift you stop by and just say hey
I'm Avante I'm really excited about the
opportunity I think I can help I applied
you got a couple message from me I
promise I'm not a weirdo I just did it
because I wanted to stick out from rest
of the pile cuz I know you guys I'm sure
for an opportunity as good as this you
probably got a lot of people who are
interested I just will promise you that
I just want a shot you say that they
will give you the interview and if they
don't someone will and once you do get
that job and you work harder than
everyone
else you turn the dial and you don't do
it for a week you don't work harder than
everyone else for a week you don't work
harder than them for a month you don't
work harder than them for 6 months you
work harder than the top guy for a year
for 2 years you're like well [__] dude
I'm already like 2 or 3 years from now
yeah I said it was a season but on the
other side of this season is everything
else that you want and so if I say Devon
in 36 months are you willing to give me
36 months to get yourself out of the
feeling that you have right now you're
like I'm sick and tired of being poor
I'm sick of not being able to buy stuff
for my girl that I want I'm sick not
being able to provide for my kid I want
them to be in a good zip code I want to
be able to have good school I want them
to be able to have these things there's
the price tag on that the question is
just whether or not you're willing to
pay it if you're willing to pay it crank
the dial and volume will negate luck but
you can't rely on luck you can rely on
volume cuz that I promise you
independent of race color socioeconomic
background you're like wait some race
socioeconomic backgrounds are how
someone appear uh gives them an
advantage sure but if you do it a
million times do give an advantage do
you only need one yes if there's like a
lesson I can like have you like etch
into your brain is that there's a
significant amount of money and
opportunity that sits on the other side
of being willing to be rejected by
stranger if you get rejected a thousand
times you are no worse off than you are
right now in fact you're better why cuz
you have a thousand times experience and
so you either learn or you win which
means in both cases by doing you win by
default I'll give you a little analogy
so let's say you and your buddy are
think about asking a girl to prompt
it'll make sense in a second and your
buddy's like ah man I want to ask Nicole
and you're like all right man why don't
you go ask her it's like ah well she
says no he's like well then you're in
the exact same position you are now
which is you have no prom date you will
also have no prom date but you'll have
experience of asking one WR what happens
when you talk to the next girl you'll
probably be a little less nervous and
you probably realize that you'll survive
you will live if you hear enough and if
you ask a 100 girls do you think one of
them will say yes to your prom date
probably and in that situation what are
you now better off than you were before
you asked the moral of the story there
is that you lose nothing from no you
only stand something to gain from yeses
and one yes can change your entire life
and so if you're willing to be rejected
and see the rejections as you learning
meaning you win and see the yeses as you
also winning then you can't lose and
everybody else around you who's poor is
going to convince you otherwise they're
going to be like why you still doing
this man stop bothering those people man
you're never going to get the job man
you need to readjust your expectations
set your goals lower hey that stuff's
not for us right they're going to tell
you those things because the thing is is
that you have something that I do not
have and that many people won't have is
that you have a hard [__] beginning
you have a harder and bigger monster to
slay but the bigger the monster the more
epic the hero and so these are the
stories that you're going to someday
tell and these are going to be the
sermons that you're going to be able to
give to other Avantes in the future if
you can't even muster the willingness to
fail for yourself be willing to fail for
your kid for the story that you're going
to tell them and be willing to fail for
the hundred other thousand other Avantes
that you'll be able to someday tell your
story to so they can get out of their
situation so I didn't have time to say
that but hopefully I give you a couple
more minutes that give you a little more
context I think I can speak confidently
for all mo Nation we're all rooted for
you